[Music]
TV producing workflows are very complex
on their layer and requires an
integration with back-end broadcast
systems that can deliver content to our
digital platform Nevada provides that
integration as well as provides
unpromoted software and hardware for
both live and VOD and combined with
their sass platform it enables us to do
video management in video delivery to
multiple endpoints including mobile as
well as water web via our content
management systems Cox Media Group is an
integrated broadcast publishing direct
marketing and digital media company the
core of our business is television radio
and newspaper
so the Envato platform really allowed us
to design a simpler and much more
flexible video architecture and it
really helped to take the friction out
of integrating between our broadcast
publishing video plants our CMS and the
video platform when we looked at
audience trend audience is moving from
traditional broadcast television
watching to watching videos on the web
on the desktop be watching on laptops to
watching on the mobile devices one of
our key goals is to be where our
audiences so when we wanted to try to
solve for that we were looking for a
platform that allows us to seamlessly be
available where our audiences and water
provides a great platform and an API
that allows us to have the same player
across all of these different very
content platforms and when we looked at
the kind of content we want to provide
we want to make both our live video
content and video on-demand be available
on all these platforms and that would be
were able to achieve we've done what a
platform video at a TV station source
for multiple points you could have
end-user submitted video from the field
you have camera folks and reporters that
are out in the field of covering news
events as well as live coverage that are
coming from the broadcast systems so all
of that is key input into the invited
platform that allows those TV producers
to cut in
and edit as they see fit and then
provide that content out to the content
management systems what we were looking
for in our video solution is a full
integrated end-to-end solution for video
right it was key for us that the
solution have a very tight integration
to a broadcast production system like
avid it was important to us that it has
robust input capabilities ability to get
files through FTP MRSS you name it we
needed that on the other end of the
scale we needed strong output mechanisms
rule-based syndication and things like
that the SAS platform was a perfect
niche fit for us from that standpoint
we've rolled the Envato platform to our
10 TV stations with great success we've
also integrated with our Nielsen
measurement platform we are about to
bring on our radio stations in the very
near future so if you combine that with
all of the things that we've done from a
measurement perspective both on Nielsen
and other measurement platforms envato
has been a great partner and we've had
very good success to date
you